the XFL made its return this weekend
kind of it's completely different league
than the one that debuted in 2001 and
lasted one season I watched three of the
four games not all of them not every
minute I loved the kickoff big cat
it looks like electric football when you
have ten guys on the thirty and ten guys
on the 35 standing still while the ball
is in the air and then they all start
moving once the returner catches it and
it's also a much safer play because you
don't have guys running full-speed at
each other concussive themselves or
breaking their necks which has happened
with kick returns but you know I look it
did well 3.3 million watched it on ABC
on Saturday two and a half million
watched it on on ESPN on Sunday I just
you know is it sustainable the point
that you made last week once we get into
March Madness once we get into NFL free
agency once baseball is back once
basketball NBA style starts to heat up
hockey playoffs roll around will it be
forgotten will it just be a curiosity or
will it have a footing right I agree
with you there and because it's my own
point that's why I'm agreeing with you I
just realized that we're at the end of
it sounded really smart what you said
and then I realized you were just
quoting me but I watched it Mike I
watched most of the games it's okay like
I I liked it it was better than the AF
it's not NFL and I don't think it's ever
gonna be the NFL and that's really what
it comes down to me is that the rules
are great I I love that the NFL will be
forced to adapt to some of these rules
you mentioned the kickoff rule I also
really really enjoyed the three-point
rule because it feels like teams are
still in it you know what I mean when
you're down 17 points it's still a two
score game that adds a little intrigue
to the whole you know affair my problem
is not only the schedule of hey when
other sports get kicking when playoffs
come for the NBA and March Madness all
this you're gonna be tuning into that
it's just the quality of play is never
gonna be the NFL just watching doing
this show for the last two hours
watching Cam Newton highlights watching
you know whoever who else we shall fill
Rivers highlights watching dak Prescott
highlights you realize the quality to
play in the NFL is it's such a level
and to take a step back and watch
quarterbacks that can't make it in the
NFL and a lot of them have tried and
failed it's just different football is
just not the same level so well I'll
probably continue to watch
I won't invest a super large amount of
time into it knowing that at the end of
the day if there's March Madness on I'm
probably watching March Madness I will
be watching March Madness the star of
the week for week one was PJ Walker who
used to be known as Phillip Walker who
had three pre seasons with the cult's
never played in a regular season game
never made it to the 53-man roster he
was the best player this past weekend at
least as it relates to the award that
they gave out he had four touchdown
passes for the Houston Roughnecks in
their 37 to 17 win over the LA Wildcats
oh my god how do I remember the score of
that game and the scoring wasn't as much
as really I thought it would be and I
don't like the fact that they've got the
three levels of extra point and they
always go for one I know one from the to
go for two from the five at a minimum
Mike it's so funny when you watch the
XFL that that hit me right away where
you have a bunch of guys who are
coaching who are cast off we're maybe
trying to get back in the NFL Kevin
Kevin Gilbride you know cast off in 2013
Marc Trestman fired by the Bears he
obviously was at the Ravens were a
little bit then in CFL but for the
majority of the guys who are coaching
outside of maybe Bob Stoops they didn't
willingly walk away from the NFL or
high-level college football it was their
time so they're all trying to get back
into this high level football the NFL
and you'd think the way to get back into
it is to be aggressive to throw it down
the field to go for 3-4 go for it on
fourth down yet the inner football guy
comes over and they say we got to do the
most conservative thing possible it's
crazy it's so it's actually like a great
sociological or psychological experiment
to watch football guys trying to get
back to where they once were and doing
it with the most conservative route they
can possibly take and it's ridiculous
because look I understand coaches don't
like to do the unconventional thing if
you do the conventional thing and it
doesn't work then nobody can Curtis
you do something unconventional you get
criticized there's no convention right
new there should just have agreed we're
just gonna go for to let the the default
is we're gonna go for two
we'll go for one if it's a tie game even
then don't you want a little more space
hell I'd put it at the 10 every time and
go for three get me all the room to work
with down here yes absolutely I'm sure
someone will do an analytical deep dive
into the XFL and you should go for three
every single time it's awesome do it
here's another point that Peter King and
I made earlier this week the DC
defenders had 17,000 people and change--
in a 20,000 seat stadium it felt like an
exciting game the New York Guardians had
17,000 and change in 82,000 seat MetLife
Stadium it felt like an empty venue and
that why don't they have all these teams
playing in 20,000 seat stadiums I mean I
know that it's some level you want to
say well if this really takes off we
don't want to be capped at 20,000 but to
get started for the first year or two
you need to be realistic about how many
people are gonna show up and if you get
17,000 a week one who's gonna be there
week eight or nine and and it just looks
awful on TV to have those shoot the
upper deck completely empty in all of
these stadiums playing stadiums they
don't have an upper deck I agree I agree
and there's a lot of mls stadiums out
there and a lot of them are built to
20,000 capacity
I agree the DC defenders game felt
different than the other games because
you felt like you were watching a packed
house and people were very invested also
Cardale Jones is another reason why you
need some big names and I know you know
we've seen the Colin Kaepernick news the
last couple days about how he wanted a
lot of money which he should have
because he's an NFL you know quarterback
but how about you know Johnny Manziel or
Tim Tebow like getting these type of
names these big names would make more
people tuned in I tuned in on Saturday
because I wanted to see how Cardale
Jones is doing I wanted to see hey why
isn't this worked out because I always
thought Cardale Jones was a good
quarterback and his run at Ohio State
was incredible so those type of names
are very important to keep people
invested
and keep people wanting to tune in
seeing how these players are doing if
you were Trevor Lawrence the Clemson
quarterback who can't enter the NFL
Draft until April of 2021 what would it
take how much money would it take to get
you to leave Clemson and play in the XFL
and knowing that you can do it this
season and next season how much per year
I would do it for forty million dollars
forty oh my god
yeah we'll ask yourself this Mike what's
his insurance ten games I know but
what's design insurance policy okay he
already has an insurance policy and then
what will he make guaranteed being the
number one pick in the NFL Draft between
35 and 40 million on a four-year deal
all right so I do yeah 40 million I
think I think he'd do it for less than I
think 39 I think he could get him for 39
well I know she at 40 so I think between
five and ten million he's still gonna
play at Clemson for free he's gonna play
15 more games at Clemson for free why
not pay it pay I'll play 20 at the XFL
and make 20 million dollars oh 54.5 you
got your soluti that's McMahon get out
of here everybody have a great day see
you Thursday
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports